MARU AHUES: Hi.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Maru.
And with me today, I have
Youssef Attalla from Orbitz.
Today, we have a
very exciting show.
We're going to go over
the Orbitz integration
with the Wallet Objects API.
This is the second show we're
doing to showcase the Orbitz
integration with Google Wallet.
The Wallet Object's API
is a simple platform
that allows developers
to build digital versions
of physical cards that can
be stored in Google Wallet,
such as loyalty cards, boarding
passes, offers, and more.
It also allows you to
engage your customers
through real time updates,
location-based notifications,
and messaging.
If you watched last
week's GDL, you
see how Orbitz integrated
with the Instant Buy API
to speed up checkout.
If you haven't
watched that video,
go ahead and watch
it after this one.
Today, Youssef is
going to walk us
through their integration
with the Wallet Objects API
and go over some
integration questions
and do a demo of how
it works with India.
Hi, Youssef.
How are you?
Thanks for joining us.
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: Hi Maru.
Thanks for having me.
MARU AHUES: We're so
glad to have you here.
Why don't we go over some
questions first, and then
let's do a demo of how the
account sign-up and the linking
works from within our app?
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
of why did Orbitz decide to
integrate the Orbitz Rewards
Program into Google Wallet?
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: Sure.
The idea was to reach the large
user base of the Google Wallet
app in order to drive awareness
of the Orbitz Awards Loyalty
Program that we just
launched last October.
And this has also increased
memberships on our website.
MARU AHUES: So now that you guys
are done with the integration,
how easy or difficult was it
to integrate with the Wallet
Objects API?
YOUSSEF ATTALLA:
Oh, great question.
So, you know, working
with the new API
always comes with its
own set of challenges.
But it also comes with a
great learning experience.
So while some parts
of the documentation
were very well described and the
steps were very easy to follow,
some other parts
were evolving as we
are working on that feature.
I do have to mention, though,
that we did get a great support
from our Google
contact, aka Maru.
Thanks for that.
And that definitely helped
speeding up the process
and make it as
smooth as possible.
MARU AHUES: It was also
fun working with you guys.
So if I book a hotel
on Orbitz, when
do I get my Orbucks
updated in the app?
Do I get them update the
same day or the next day?
Can you tell us a little bit
about that process on updates?
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: Yeah.
So as of now, it takes 24
hours for the Orbucks balance
to be updated.
And the way we do that is
that we run a daily job that
checks the status of
our loyalty members
who registered or linked
through the Google Wallet app.
And we get the most recent
version of the loyalty object,
compare that to
our local database.
If there's any differences
in their Orbucks
balance or their
status, then we have
to push a change to this
object through the API
calls in the documentation.
This way, next time
the user open the app,
they will see their
updated balance.
MARU AHUES: So let's
take a look at the demo
and how I can book a hotel on
Orbitz and earn some Orbucks.
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: Sure.
Let me show you how.
So here we go.
We go to the Hotels path.
Let's look for a city.
Let's say, Las Vegas.
Somewhere warmer than
here because it's
pretty cold in Chicago now.
And just pick a dates.
Some time in April.
And search.
All right.
So now, I get a list of hotels.
Looks like there's some deals.
Let's look for a good one.
And yeah, that seems
like a good deal.
Fits my budget.
Let's check the pictures.
All right.
Looks good to me.
Convinced.
So select a room like that one.
And now we can see the summary.
I see the mobiles
deal is applied.
And see this form?
I don't want to really
fill all this information.
So now that we integrated
the Google+ sign-in,
so what I can do is I can click
Sign In for faster booking.
Google+.
Pick a Google account.
And boom, now I'm signed
into Orbitz through Google+.
And since I'm a
loyalty member, you
can see here that I can
earn $1.89 in Orbucks
if I made this booking.
And also, because I'm
signed in through Google+,
if I clicked on Buy
with Google Wallet,
I'll find the credit
card [INAUDIBLE].
I don't need to add
any more information.
I just click Continue.
Display the credit card.
Check the information.
Confirm everything is right.
And book.
Now, if everything
went fine, we'll
see the confirmation screen
with the record locator
for this booking
and also tell you
how many Orbucks you
earned on this booking.
Boom.
That's how easy it is.
MARU AHUES: Wow, that was
pretty easy and quick.
I really like the new Google+
integration that you guys did.
So now that I
earned some Orbucks,
let's take a look at how we
can link our existing Orbitz
Rewards account
into Google Wallet
and then take a look at my
points that we just earned.
YOUSSEF ATTALLA:
Sure, let me show you.
So here we have the
Google Wallet app.
Then I go to Loyalty
Programs, Add a Program,
and look for Orbitz.
Here you go.
And see here, that's the
Orbitz reward description.
I'll get up to 5% on hotels
on our mobile apps, plus 1%.
And since I'm
already a member, I'm
going to click on a
member with my email.
That's the same email that
I used to sign in on Orbitz.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] program.
Now there's a verify first and
last name and my phone number.
Click on Verify.
And here you go.
So now we see the Orbucks.
And if you click
on this card, you
get the loyalty object that
we talked about earlier.
And you see the updated balance.
MARU AHUES: Great.
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: That's it.
MARU AHUES: It can't get
any easier than that.
So you open the app and you look
for the program Orbitz Rewards.
Then you just enter
the same email address
that we used to create our
Orbitz Rewards account online.
And then you can check
your points, right?
YOUSSEF ATTALLA: Yep.
MARU AHUES: So the
Google Wallet app also
allows users to sign up for
a new loyalty program in case
they haven't signed up
already or of course
link to an existing
account the way
that you just saw in the demo.
Google will post
[INAUDIBLE] request
with the user-provided
information
to the merchant's
web service URL.
And then the
merchant's web service
needs to respond back to
Google with either a success
or failure.
And in the case of
a success, then you
need to send back
the loyalty object
that will save on that
user, which is in this case
a loyalty card.
Youssef, thanks so
much for joining us.
It was great to have you.
YOUSSEF ATTALLA:
Thanks for inviting me.
I really learned a lot from
working under this project.
MARU AHUES: And be sure to
check out the Orbitz Loyalty
Program, Orbitz Rewards,
and Google Wallet.
And join now to start
earning some Orbucks
or link your existing
account if you already
have one to keep track
of your Orbucks as well.
For more videos
on Wallet Objects,
please go to
developers.google.com/live/wallet/.
Or you can also find us
at Google+ +Google Wallet.
And thanks for joining us
for another week of Google
Developers Live.
See you next time.